hello i'm dario gill and i'm speaking
with you
from the yorktown heights research
laboratory
it serves as the headquarters of ibm
research and today
is a great pleasure for me to share with
you
a perspective of the quantum computing
era that is emerging
and the implications that it will have
for science for discovery
and for business at large it is clear
that the world is being challenged with
ever more complex problems to solve the
coronavirus
and kovite 19 is a powerful example
of the challenges we confront in
humanity as we try to
understand some of the deep functioning
of nature
and the implications it has for all of
us in our societies
here in the context of dealing with a
structure that is no more than 100
nanometers inside
we're struggling to figure out ways how
to deactivate
the functioning of the virus now we know
that computation can help us
if we look at the inner structure of the
virus
we see these spiking proteins and these
proteins can be modeled
and understood and therefore we could
use them to then explore
different kinds of compounds that could
deactivate how they function
here supercomputers can come to help us
we can use these most powerful computers
to model
this protein structure and
we can use another powerful force which
is
the powerful force of joining the
resources and the capability
across institutions in moments of crisis
it is particularly important that we all
come together
and that's why we were very proud to
coalesce and create
in partnership with the federal
government
and other institutions in the tech
sector as well as academia
the kovit 19 high performance computing
consortia
where 30 plus members have aggregated
over 400 petaflops of computing power
and over a hundred thousand nodes to go
and pursue
a broad portfolio of projects that can
help us understand the pandemic
understand the evolution of the virus
and accelerate the pace
at which we can develop antivirals and
ultimately
vaccines what this tells us
is that when confronting with
exponential problems
we have enormous computational demands
in fact exponential problems
require exponential computation and
today
we're fighting the pandemic within the
context of the computational paradigm we
have
the world of bits but there's another
computational paradigm that is emerging
and is the world of qubits so moving
forward
bits and qubits will be foundational
computational paradigms with which we
can tackle
complex problems in the world so let's
try to understand the difference between
them
and where the power of qubits rise if we
look at the left hand side
it's a way to describe and we're going
to use these diagrams
throughout the presentation to unpack
the power
we're seeing a circle and two dots when
the circle when the dot is in the north
pole that's a zero when it's in the
south pole is a one
that's a classical bit to state now a
cubit
is the unit of information in quantum
world
and here we get to have let's depict it
as a sphere
a zero and a one and we can have them in
this
superposition state but we have a
special trick that is available to us
not only we can have them positioned in
this sphere
but imagine that each one of this now is
like a little moon
that is in the sphere and we can rotate
the moon so here you're seeing
that um the bottom sphere has been
rotated slightly so that's why you see a
little bit of blue and pink
and we could rotate it all the way so
here's a 180 degree
shift so we have this notion of
phase quantum affords us
three super powers that are exhibited in
the qubits
they are the powers of superposition the
power
of interference and the power of
entanglement
so let's unpack those the principle of
superposition is actually quite
straightforward
to understand so let's start on the left
hand side we have our north pole zero
or south pole one and if we add those
two states
now we have a superposition qubit that
has both a zero
and a one simultaneously north and south
pole now the right diagram is the same
but now we're gonna do a little trick
we're to apply a gate a quantum gate and
what we did here is remember we get to
change now we get to rotate these little
moons
right so we've rotated it 180 degrees
and now we have a one
so now when we do the addition of zero
plus one we end up with a superposition
state
but notice that it's different than the
one on the left we have
still a zero and a one but now with a
rotated state
for the one now that is going to be very
powerful
to then leverage a second really
interesting thing which is the principle
of interference and this is not an
operation that we get to perform in
classical bit world
so here in this example we have a zero
and a one on the left
plus this new state that we created
which is also a zero now one
but with this rotated moon when we do
this now
we get to interfere those two states and
notice
something really interesting happens
we've cancelled
the one state and we've ended up with
that zero state we've done that because
we've
interfered the states so the next
opportunity that we have right now
is how many states can we create and
the beautiful thing in quantum is we get
to create an exponential number of
states
so let's look at a system that has five
qubits
in this case we're depicting these
qubits as independent qubits right
you're seeing them on the left
zeros and ones and they're getting
multiplied we have five of them
so the number of states that we can
create now in our quantum computer
depicted
on the sphere on the right it's 2 to the
power
of the number of qubits we have in this
case we have 5 so 2 to the power of 5 is
32
states so we're seeing 32 of those
little moons
notice that in this case we did not
incorporate any phase
they're all pink the powerful aspect
of using this property called
entanglement in the quantum
world is that we can create now states
like the one depicted on the right
where we have these combinations of pink
and blue
where that end state cannot
be described as the independent
product of these five qubits in this
case since we have 32 states
what this tells us is actually something
very profound
and that is that you could have an n
state in your quantum system that you're
using to process information
that cannot be described
as the independent components of the
qubits that make the whole state
there's a lot in there it's a very
profound statement
and it is the basis of the power and the
complexity
of quantum machines so let's bring that
all together to give you an intuition
for how an algorithm works in a quantum
computer
what we do is that at the beginning
let's say in this case
we have a five qubit quantum computer is
that
we prepare the computer to be in a
superposition of states
2 to the power of 5 32 you have those 32
dots that you see on the left in pink
then we have to encode the problem we
have to inject data
into the quantum machine the way that
happens is that that encoding
gets done through entanglement so notice
that what we've done now
is that some of those states are now
changing phase you're seeing those
depicted
as blue and some are pink
now in our machines not only we have the
superposition we have
exploited the property of entanglement
to do the encoding of information
and the principle of interference comes
from the fact that we can now take these
states
and combine them and interfere them with
one another
in such a way that we get to cancel
things out and
maximize the right answer so many things
fall away and the right answer gets
maximized
we perform a measurement and we get a
result
notice how very different that is from
classical bit based operations
and there is a really important
relationship
between this entangled property
and the amount of information that we
can process
and this relationship is exponential
what this
table shows is the number of
classical bits zeros and ones that are
required
to represent that complex tangle
entangled state that i just described
and here's an amazing number by the time
you have a hundred perfect cuvettes that
are entangled with one another
if you needed to describe them using
zeros and ones
you would need to devote every atom of
planet earth
to store those zeros on ones clearly
that's not possible
in fact by the time you have 280 cubits
you will need every atom of the known
universe
so that it tells you that this is
exponential relationship between the
special property of entanglement
and the representation of information
why does this matter
well it matters because it turns out
that despite how powerful or of
classical computers
are the reality is that there's a vast
set of problems in the world that they
cannot tackle
from an information theory perspective
we would say that
really classical computers can tackle
easy problems things that don't have an
exponential number of variables in them
remember in the case of the virus as an
example
that molly nature is an example of an
exponential problem
but so are other problems like factoring
and problems in optimization in fact
there's a vast number of problems in the
world of mathematics
that have that character and those
problems are deeply important
for business the world over for
optimization and in the future and
machine learning
and developing new molecules and
chemistry and the life sciences and
beyond
now the reality of it is that you say
well that's very interesting and the
theoretical underpinning but can you
actually
build these machines and access these
machines
and we also recognize that for most of
history to access computing power
you had to build it and maintain it
yourself but now
we're in a situation where even these
very special machines quantum computers
can be accessed by anyone in the world
in fact the system looks as follows you
can sit in front of your terminal
write your program you can send your
zeros and ones and when they get
here to the laboratory where we are as
an example we convert those zeros and
ones to microwave pulses they operate
about five gigahertz
and we send them dyno cryostat that
operates about 15 millikelvin
temperature
and we get to use those microwave pulses
to manipulate these qubits
to perform those superposition and
entanglement and interference operations
and then return the result to the user
who is using
a regular classical computer this is
what
the inside of these beautiful machines
look like i say beautiful because
they're really you know gorgeous pieces
of of engineering and science
and you're seeing the inside of this
cryostat uh you know that uh golden
chandelier
and those wires are the means by which
uh you know we send those microwave
pulses down
at the very bottom of that golden
chandelier
is where we have the quantum processor
itself
where we perform those operations so if
we go and look inside
this is what a quantum processor looks
like
in our case in ibm we use
superconducting technology
specifically we use a qubit device
called the transmon qubit
and what you're seeing is uh you know at
the core of it if you look at the bottom
right hand side
we have a device which is called a
joseph junction that is about 100
nanometers by 100 nanometers
you know roughly the size of the
the corona virus in fact so 100
nanometers by 100 nanometers
and essentially allows us to create an
artificial atom
with a ground state and an excited state
that is the basis then
uh with which we can couple it to other
qubits and you're seeing on the right
hand side those wiggly lines
that we've labeled microwave resonators
and that's what allows us to couple the
qubits with one another
and then perform these entanglement and
interference operations that give
quantum computing its power
we build these quantum chips here in the
laboratory from which
i'm talking to you today in yorktown
heights now
with those units of information the very
important thing that is being created
is a rich and vibrant world of quantum
circuits
this is what's really next in the world
of quantum
so let's explore them a little bit a
quantum circuit
is going to be the unit of value for
your business
the qubit is a unit of information but a
circuit
is the unit of computation so let's try
to understand
what is a quantum circuit and let's look
at its anatomy
this is what a quantum circuit looks
like so let's decompose this into pieces
the qubits are depicted by these
horizontal lines in this case we're
depicting a circuit that has
four qubits that you see here shown
now the gates are how we control the
qubits
and you read the gates from left to
right
so it's the sequence of placing these
gates that is the basis
of creating a circuit to construct this
circuit we have
many quantum gates available to control
these circuits
so this is analogous to the way
we do controls in the world of bits
so in the world of bits we're all
accustomed to that you know
behind the scenes we have these ands and
ores and knots etc
so similarly in the world of qubits we
have a different set of operations
remember some of those operations are
the very idea of doing the rotation to
one of our little moons
that i was depicting before right
introducing a phase change and i
showed before a z operation that
performed that rotation
that allows us to do that interference
operation
so let's do a comparison between a
classical circuit
and a quantum circuit here in a
classical circuit
what you witness here is that you don't
get to see blue moons right there's no
rotations everything here is pink
and that you got these single states
that in this case were seen moving the
sphere
but notice what a contrast is going to
look like when we actually implement
a quantum circuit so let's look at what
a quantum circuit looks like
so in this case we're implementing
grover's algorithm which is a basis for
performing search operations first of
all you notice
the complexity has increased greatly
right we have these superposition states
now you're seeing that we get to perform
these operations
where we do rotations so here you're
seeing blue
we're performing operations of
interference you're seeing some of those
little moons getting bigger and bigger
in size that is telling us we're
converting to some important answer
and that is how we get finally to to the
answer so if we put them side by side
just visually you can get a sense
that a classical circuit can never
exploit
the vast computational space that a
quantum
circuit can it's it's the visualizations
give you this intuition
of the richness with which we can access
this large state
and the beautiful part of this is that
we can have many classes of circuits
to do different functions so for example
this is a circuit
that is designed to model financial risk
here's an example of a circuit for the
world of chemistry right to measure the
energy of lithium hydride that is
important for the development of new
battery technology
here is a circuit that is a unique form
of a classifier a new
approach to do machine learning
applications so
what we're very excited to share with
all of you
is the fact that libraries of these
circuits are emerging and that
there's going to be this richness of
circuits that allow you to perform
different applications that we are going
to be able to embed
in the programs that we all use
and create to create business value
libraries of circuits
that get embedded in classical programs
that now combine the best of classical
programming and the best of quantum
power
it is important to realize that not all
circuits have equal value
and that there will be circuits that you
can implement classically
far far better because if you're not
exploiting
that computational space if you're not
exploiting these ideas of superposition
and interference
and entanglement in the proper way you
don't get there
now we're very fortunate that some of
the best minds in the world are thinking
really hard about this problem
about what are the classes of circuits
that
give us a path to quantum advantage and
i'll highlight this seminal paper that
was published last year in science by
sergey bravi and his collaborator
now sergey works here in the yorktown
lab and he is absolutely one of the top
theorists in the world in quantum
and this paper what uh him and his
collaborators shown
is the fact that you can have shallow
circuits meaning
these kind of quantum circuits that
don't have a massive amount of depth
to them that have a provable
theoretical advantage compared to the
classical implementation this is the
first time where we have a mathematical
proof
that these classes of circuits have
proven advantages compared to classical
ones
so guided by these theoretical insights
that are so profound
it is how we are chartering the path of
creating these libraries of circuits
and this is how you consume that you're
not going to need to learn a new quantum
programming language
you can use your favorite language and
from there
call upon these circuits that implement
these special functions
from there map them to the right quantum
systems
that we have available on ibm cloud and
then return the answer
back to you as the programmer now i know
you hear that some are telling you that
you got to learn you know a new
quantum programming language we believe
that we need to exploit the richness
of all the programming languages that we
have today whether it's python or c plus
plus or whatever
really you love and that circuits
is what will provide you the quantum
value and
behind the ibm cloud you will get to
benefit from both the library
and a large portfolio of hardware
designed to implement those circuits
efficiently this is not an aspirational
future
we really have many quantum systems on
ibm cloud
here is the growth of the number of
quantum systems we have made available
on ibm cloud and to the community
since we launched the world's first
service in may
2016. you can see that at present
we have 18 quantum systems that we've
made available
through the cloud so let's go take a
look at a few so that you can see what
they look like
so welcome to uh one of our quantum
computation centers here in yorktown
uh remember i showed you that golden
chandelier before
uh where you saw those wires that went
down
all the way to the quantum processor
well this is what a quantum computer
looks like a superconducting one
when it's encased we have to protect it
for the environment so that's why it's
shielded
and all the way at the very bottom here
is where the quantum processor sits
and as i mentioned this is one of the
coldest places in the universe
right down here 15 millikelvin let's
listen for a minute to the sound of a
quantum computer
you hear like this chirping sound tintin
tintin
tintin that is linked to the flow of
gases that we pump
through the system to be able to extract
energy from the system
and cool it to the very low temperatures
let's go take a look
at some of the other key components of a
quantum computer
in this case is a control electronics
here this custom made control
electronics is how we convert the zeros
and ones to microwave pulses about five
gigahertz
and we send those pulses into the
quantum computer to perform the
quantum operations and to execute our
quantum circuits
so let's just quickly take a final look
and some of the other systems
here are the four systems out of the
18 that i mentioned to you and let's
take one last look
and one of the other ones this is one of
my favorite places in the world right
it is so wonderful to see a whole new
paradigm of computation
and one of the very first quantum
computation centers
that have ever been created and this is
how the community has grown since may
2016.
what you're seeing here is a
visualization of the number of quantum
circuits executed in the
ibm cloud quantum portfolio
and look how it has grown over the years
over 180 billion quantum circuits have
been executed
with over 230 000
users all over the world if you look now
from an institutional perspective of
companies and universities who have
joined the ibmq network by far the
largest community
of institutions collaborating and
exploiting
the power of quantum computing you can
also see
the fantastic growth and the excitement
that is behind the scenes
and what are the cases that are being
explored by this
community of institutions and businesses
well
a broad variety of problems ranging from
chemistry and developing new materials
to optimization
to artificial intelligence and to
scenario simulation
let me give you just a few examples
daimler is a wonderful partner in the
ibmq network
and in their case they're very
interested in the power of quantum
to look at advanced battery materials
and the possibilities of using quantum
for
manufacturing defect inspection in this
case i'm highlighting on the bottom
right the example an example of one of
the circuits
that are being used to perform these use
cases
or let's take out the case still still
staying in the field of chemistry and
materials
of exxon mobil in this case they're very
interested
in uh you know modeling the the thermal
reaction modeling
for petrochemical r d and here we're
seeing
some of the example uh of the circuit
that is being used to perform these
calculations and
by the way we develop these circuits
through a collaboration right
between ibm and and our partners as as
we pursue this work
let me give another example for a
different industry this is in the case
of the
you know our wonderful partner j.p
morgan chase where we work on the
problem of optimization
and here we're looking at the potential
to find better solutions to more
efficiently
than what we can do classically to
improve things like options pricing and
fraud detection
or portfolio optimization and you're
seeing here an example of circuits that
have been developed for european
derivative pricing
now when you look at the capability
today i think it's also a very important
question to say
well what is the road map you know how
much better are these systems
and how much more complex are going to
be the circuits that we're able to
execute
and for that we have developed a very
important metric
called quantum volume sometimes you may
read or hear in the popular press the
number of qubits and you know and
as a measure of progress i'll tell you
straight that
just the number of qubits in the machine
is not a good
measure of the power of a quantum
computer
there's another axis that is vitally
important and that is the error rate
in these qubits these qubits and these
cubic machines are not perfect today and
they have errors that are introduced
by the coupling of the system to the
external world
the very power of these qubits of
entanglement and those properties
are also make them both powerful and
delicate to the intersection and
connection to the outside world
so you need to lower the error rate
while you increase the qubit count
so that's what's depicted here what you
really want to do is you want to move in
the diagonal and quantum volume is a
measure that incorporates
both of those metrics and some key
additional considerations
and the good news is that we are in a
new exponential here and what we have
demonstrated
experimentally and by building systems
that we have deployed
to all the clients of the ibmq network
is that we are
at least doubling quantum volume every
year we've gone from a quantum volume of
four to eight to 16 to 32 on a yearly
basis
and we are committed to at least double
it right year-on-year basis
if we keep this space or even faster
we are going to see really spectacular
results with quantum computing
let me close with a reflection on
the urgency of science the urgency
of tackling some of the most complex
problems
in the world and i'll put that
reflection
that a revolution in discovery and a
revolution
on mission critical applications is
going to be power
by the most exciting time in computing
in 60 years
where what we're witnessing is the
convergence
of bits neurons and qubits
bits the classical world that we've all
known and the computers we've known
qubits this new fundamental way to
process
information that we explored today
and the world of neurons and neural
architectures
that are the basis of artificial
intelligence
it is not that one will eat the other
the most profound implication of what is
happening today in computing
is the convergence of bits neurons and
qubits
now this convergence is going to be
orchestrated
through a hybrid cloud architecture
and on top of it to mask the complexity
of the underlying infrastructure we are
going to be assisted by artificial
intelligence
in the way we program ai assisted
programming
the consequence of all of this coming
together
will be nothing short than a revolution
on how science itself is practiced and
the rate at which we could perform
accelerated discovery and
a whole new class of intelligent mission
critical
applications thank you